[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the President of the United
States is self-destructing we need to
give him all the help we can in his task
this is not said lightly even with this
president even in this atmosphere of
daily of not hourly crisis this is an
issue of deep regret ordinarily the last
thing in the world any American would
want as a leader bent on destroying
himself and ending his presidency but
the threat to our freedoms our heritage
our way of life our lives themselves is
so overwhelming and unprecedented that
putting aside the almost immeasurable
anger and resentment that this childish
petulant selfish man engenders it is
still with genuine sadness that we must
look at his self-destruction and say it
simply and resolutely better him than
our country Trump advisors and
confidants describe the president as
increasingly angry over the
investigation yelling at television sets
in the White House
caring coverage right Jonathan Lamar and
Julie pace of The Associated Press on
June 16th he has watched hours of TV
coverage every day sometimes even
storing morning shows on his TiVo to
watch in the evening and complain
non-stop rights Josh Dawsey at Politico
on June 15th we will ignore for a moment
the thought that somebody still has a
TiVo
the president is yelling at television
screens evoking the probably apocryphal
story of Richard Nixon in his last days
arguing with the White House paintings
of Kennedy and Lincoln yelling at
television screens let's just hope the
sets are actually on Trump for months
has bristled almost daily about the
ongoing probes rights politico's Dawsey
he has sometimes without prompting
injected I'm not under investigation
into conversations with associates and
allies that was written June 15th on
Friday June 16th Trump threw the ship
fully into reverse in a tweet that
seemed to confirm the opposite of all of
that and included the direct quote I am
being investigated by the man who told
me to fire the FBI director after
ceaseless denials about this
Trump could now adjust his inaccurate
worldview to accept what has been
obvious to everybody else since at least
the appointment of Robert Muller as
special counsel and then suddenly he
couldn't by Sunday June 18th Trump had
to have one of his mouthpieces go on
three Network shows until one of them
that Trump is being investigated and
then when pressed for details saying no
Trump isn't being investigated same
interview yes and no Trump is so sick
that he cannot continue to accept on
Sunday what he had seemed to have begun
to accept on Friday Trump still had to
preserve a corner of his fantasy world
in which he has not only never at fault
but if indisputable reality disagrees
with his delusions indisputable reality
must be wrong in some way in the June
16th tweet Trump blamed quote a man who
told me to fire the FBI director on May
11th Trump had claimed quote regardless
of recommendation I was going to fire
the FBI director now in his mind that
first statement never happened
you know of course about last week's
terrifying cabinet meeting in which
Trump claimed never has there been a
president with few exceptions who has
passed more legislation done more things
when in fact next to nothing has passed
next to nothing has been done and you
know about the 23 minutes of praise he
asked for and got from such reeking
toady's such self-serve ative zazz Rick
my hat is off to you Perry and ranks
blessing to serve you Priebus and Mike
the greatest privilege of my life pence
although in Pence's case that might be
true you devote the council's of North
Korea or perhaps the flattering of the
Roman Emperor Caligula to keep him from
killing everybody in the room or maybe
from the episode of The Twilight Zone
where the six-year-old boy has the power
to destroy everything on earth merely by
wishing it and the remaining adults vie
to appease him or less chillingly and
perhaps more in accordance with the
farce of this administration the
governor that Mel Brooks plays in his
movie Blazing Saddles who tells his
cabinet that they must protect their
phony-baloney jobs and they all join him
in saying herim
harrumph and then Brooke stops and
points at one of them and says I didn't
get a hump out of that guy and the
holdout finally says her rump and Brooke
stares and points at him again and says
you watch your ass you know of this
Monday meeting with the president of
Panama in which he said the Panama Canal
is doing quite well I think we did a
good job building it as if it was just
finished it opened on August 15 1914 and
maybe most disturbingly of all there is
this buried in a June 13th opus from
Glen thrush Maggie Haberman and Julie
Davis of the New York Times what would
have been in any other time in any other
presidency a sign of desperate personal
emotional psychological or physical
distress but which in this one this
presidency of self-destruction was
almost an afterthought about the
conflicting stories wafting out of the
White House that he might or might not
fire the special counsel quote the
president was pleased by the ambiguity
of his position on mr. Muller wrote The
Times trio on the 13th and thinks the
possibility of being fired will focus
the veteran prosecutor on delivering
what the president desires most a
blanket public exoneration this is where
the same patriotic people of this
country must see that we are not dealing
with the president who occasionally
strays into madness
but we are dealing with a madman who
occasionally successfully pretends to be
sane to look at a man who is the special
counsel a man with a long respected and
lucrative career behind him and if he
wants it more of the same ahead after
this assignment and to think for a
moment that you could get him to clear
you even if you are guilty by
threatening to fire him from a job he
did not want and does not need to assume
that your only motive in life money is
also everybody else's only motive in
life is as rational as going to the roof
of the White House and to prove yourself
invincible to jump off because you have
always believed that when it was
necessary you could fly because you have
a lot of money right now in this
atmosphere of daily if not hourly
crisis his critics as sycophants his
self-serve ative z' are not going to be
able to convince Trump that he cannot
fly
so the country will have to hope for the
best
and let him jump resist peace